you don't do this
oh I know what you wanted you weren't
invited to do this I don't get invited
anywhere does that stop me from going
places mostly yes but not today
apparently boom I don't know how this
will go because the only flow I know
comes every 28 days or so Wow this is
already the worst I'm just like a sheep
female for a Durst let's get through
this I had the second daffodil I'll
never be Danville never quite dressed to
kill rather just like roadkill
oh my from Jacksonville's I look just
like Michael Jackson it is distracting
and how do I look a similar but lection
and similar nose and close and stunted
growth I digress no I'll die gross those
my routines are my hygiene is like me
looking for love at 19 it blows my nose
cuz I'm allergic to human touch use
comedy as my crutch my star signs an
idiot curtain move very desperate first
crushes fairly elegant solution grab
event let's talk about experiment I was
on TV on eat I had a show did you see
neither did anyone else kind of
embarrassing but here's a comparison I
cut my own bangs not once but twice it
was not nice it was brutal with like a
hamburger bun mixed with the human
Labradoodle terrible choice oh and my
voice its rolls-royce up awful sounds my
Kaden posa found is to float they'd
rather drown or express some sympathy to
me because they believe that I have a
learning disability I don't but I do
have a dog that cannot socialize and
then look behind my eyes lids I cannot
doesn't it you can't sexualize if
awkwardness for currency I'd be Oprah
[ __ ] Winfrey but it's not it's not
unique it's pretty tired so just let it
sleep and my friends they share my ABC
they call us Holy Trinity but let's be
real what do you see a Dixie 2:30 well
two outta three of us are Dixie Chicks
by there's still a lot to defend but God
let's get to the end before I repress
almost dressing in the country bags
again thank you for listening and thank
you for witnessing three solid minutes
of something uninteresting something
unwritten something so crippling a white
brawl rapping oh my god this is
sickening this is so blistering to your
ears I'm sorry to your ears your
beautiful ears are you still listening
why are you listening
this is belittling now you're inhibiting
me but please subscribe before you go
cause you don't look like a scroll
tongue I don't know